I think I was called like the lone wolf
like obviously I'm the lone wolf I'm the
only conservative on the show we're
gonna we're gonna disagree Megan McCain
is shutting down any and all Feud rumors
surrounding her and her co-hosts on the
view this has been a really really rough
few weeks for me and I mean shutting
them down hard I could not do the show
if she leaves I go the 35 year old
conservative co-host stop by watch what
happens live with Andy Cohen on
Wednesday where she addressed this
moment girl please stop talking please
stop talking right now I want to hug
this out okay that's I'm okay with that
yeah that awkward moment where Whoopie
straight-up
shushed her on the view it was rough
and I will say that she was having a bad
day and we talked about it that night
and the next day and you know it's live
TV and it's really intense stressful
times for everyone and I adore her she
apologized affair she apologized on
there we all up on the show it's live
it's every day and I forgive her and I
love her and just in case you didn't get
the message that it's all good between
them she doubled down saying this I
could not do the show if she leaves I go
like Whoopi is the anchor of the show
and my life there and she always picks
us up when we're done so she jumps I
drop like Whoopi is like but like I
adore her and I need her as the madhuri
well damn and if you're wondering how
things are between Megan and the rest of
the panel she had this to say when asked
about the rumored backstage tension on
the show and whether Megan's co-stars
speak to her off-camera good lord
yes yes I mean and again anyone who
comes to the show I mean Joe and I are
oftentimes in the corner talking about
like things we hit and things we missed
during the break so I think you can't
we're going to show where the host don't
speak back in November Megan and joy sat
down for a chat with et cameras rolling
and they said it really is nothing but
love between them what is the one thing
you want the public to know about our
relationship that we like each other
they keep writing things about how we
can't stand each other it's really hurts
my feelings it genuinely hurts my
feelings because our dressing rooms are
next door to each other and you and I
have the same mo
reactions to things sometimes in
different ways but we're both upset
equally the equal amount of the same
things and I wish people would give us a
break but back to Meghan on watch what
happens live she also admitted to having
a recent tiff with her now former
co-host and a longtime friend Abby
Huntsman we did get in a fight which is
a very small fight in my friend fight
and all friendships have ups and downs
and it was sort of bizarre for me and I
think bizarre for her to have the fact
that we got in one fight that two years
we worked together on the show to be you
know put under dissection in the media
to be weaponized because so there would
soon it's cruel Abby announced earlier
this month that she was leaving the talk
show to focus on her dad John Huntsman
Jr's campaign for governor of Utah Abby
and I've been friends for over ten years
our parents were friends and politics
who worked at Fox together part of
reason why she came to the view is
because we were friends we are still
very good friends we are very close I
just talked to her yesterday morning
she's campaigning with her dad I think
she was genuinely conflicted about her
dad running for governor and her not
helping and that is the reason why she
left
as for the reported rift between them
Megan says that the whole damn thing was
just blown out of proportion I I didn't
want her to go selfishly because I
thought she was an amazing co-host and I
just having a friend there has been
lovely but it's been really emotionally
taxing to have like our friendship used
this way in the media and well the view
never seems to disappoint us when it
comes to those heated discussions Megan
told et that's part of the show's appeal
I think that's why people like the show
is they know it's not scripted and they
know it's not we're not being phony and
I'm not trying to placate to an audience
I try and just remind myself that I'm
representing 50 percent of the country
I'm representing a bunch of women even
though I only have one chair well that's
it for today of course you can count on
et to bring you all the latest from the
ladies of the view so make sure to keep
it locked right here until next time I'm
Hallie Stevens see you soon